why does help the charts cost so much
why does some policies like my mother's
cost over $1,500 a month when can I stop
walking forward the answers right now
[Music]
imagine you want to order a pizza when
you want beats a pie from stereotyped
pets some order you want order a cheese
pizza but the government passes a
regulation mandating that all pizzas
contain at least 70 toppings that's a
price immutable
now toppings are great I like topics but
mandating toppings would certainly make
pizza more expensive well the same is
true with health insurance where I buy
my health insurance in Virginia there's
70 benefits that the government requires
all policies to cover I want any
coverage at all I have to pay for all
seventy shouldn't we get to choose what
we want our plans to cover when you have
a health scare cuz you're mugged by a
bear you won't come exactly if you want
coverage for something catastrophic or
intestines or school like a bus of
fazool okay that's a little bit much are
you children please but my wife can't
conceive so my policy requires our
purchase coverage for substance abuse
and hysterectomies but I've never taken
a drug in my life and I don't have a
uterus but the coverage is mandatory so
I have to pay 12 states require all
policies to cover acupuncture others
require all policies to cover massage
therapy for states even require all
policies to cover holistic healing well
the bad news is you might not make it
but the good news is I do have oregano
each state requires between 13 and 17
mandates and if you want to purchase
your policy from a state with fewer
mandates tough luck
the government makes it virtually
impossible every coverage benefit just
makes health insurance more expensive
shouldn't we be able to choose which
benefits we want to pay for it would
certainly make health insurance policies
like my mother's more affordable
[Applause]
oh I tells you all you need meds like
Bob Dole that's amore
when your wife's birth things on is like
empty Collazo
[Music]